welcome back to CBS morning's our earth
365 series is all about the health of
our planet and this morning we're
focusing in on an alliance of small
island States threatened by rising sea
levels one of those States is the
Western Pacific nation of Palau while it
struggles to adapt to climate change the
country is also embroiled in a debate
over the future of the ocean's resources
CBS Sunday Morning correspondent Lee
Cowan went for a swim with the former
President of Palau to see a marine
Paradise in peril
foreign
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Palau
climate change is hardly a new idea for
thousands of years their ancestors have
been carefully managing their most
precious natural gift
their ocean
the turquoise Waters and the Maze that
are the rock islands are pristine almost
as if man had never been here before
palawans call it the nest of life
the waters here are teeming with more
than 1500 species of fish more than 700
species of coral there's so much to look
at it's pretty easy to get lost in all
the dazzling display
it's unbelievable
where's the boat
the person with our boat is none other
than the former President of Palau Tommy
Remy gassau Jr who did in fact come back
for us we are in an area where
absolutely no commercial fishing
whatsoever nothing no you in his first
term in 2006 he joined with other
micronesian nations and banned
commercial fishing and drilling across
30 percent of palau's waters
that was a start but Remy gassau wanted
more he grew up in these Waters as a boy
he'd actually swim inside some of the
Region's most famous underwater
residents palau's giant clams we would
climb inside the giant Plum inside the
plane into play the clam and this old
clowns would not wouldn't be able to
close all the way so you're kind of safe
in a way
when he was re-elected in 2015 he set
about what would become his legacy he
argued for a full 80 percent closure of
palau's waters that's an area bigger
than the state of California
if you're concerned about the welfare of
the people if you're concerned about
maintaining the population of the Marine
Resources then you have to do something
drastic in 2020 the Palau National
Marine Sanctuary finally became one of
the largest protected Marine areas in
the world
it doesn't matter where you live
you are either a part of the problem or
part of the solution but the sanctuary's
future is now uncertain palau's current
president serango whips Jr is
considering reducing the size of the
protected area in an effort to jumpstart
palau's local economy it makes it
challenging because when I talk to my
friends in the Pacific about closing off
large areas they're like well what's
going to happen to the revenue that
we're currently getting when the foreign
fishing fleet left Palau it took with it
a lot of jobs but since there's no
domestic fishing fleet here that meant
it also removed the source of tuna from
much of the local market when you go too
far in One Direction what do you think
happens they revolt and they want to get
rid of everything that's not what we're
doing we're trying to optimize and
actually improve and make it better
that's welcome news to fisherman Jackson
norinus I think the intent of the law
also was to develop the local fishing
industry people like me he says it cost
him as much as fifteen thousand dollars
to fuel up just one of his boats but he
says the 20 where he is allowed to fish
isn't actually where the fish are
there's no fish here come and visit whip
says it's not about percentages it's
about finding the sustainable balance
between protection and production so
essentially what you're saying is bigger
isn't necessarily better right so it's
about replacing what's lost to make sure
that that resource that we're protecting
still has a benefit back to the people
former president Tommy remagasau doesn't
buy that economic argument to him that
sounds a lot like the foreign fishing
Lobby casting its political net just to
get back in the market it's not like
we're dying because of lack of fishing
revenues we more than can make up for it
but whatever happens he says at least
the debate has focused attention on
Palau which for Generations has been
doing more to protect the world's oceans
than countries thousands of times its
size we're happy that people take notice
of what Palau is doing but that's the
idea take notice and do something
for CBS mornings I'm Lee Cowan in Palau